[Music]
our next guest is the creative mind
behind some of your favorite children's
book bashti Harrison created the images
in the popular hair love she's also the
illustrator and author of little
dreamers little leaders and Little
Legends her newest book is called Big in
it Harrison beautifully visualizes how
hurtful words can stay with kids and she
encourages them to embrace their
emotions and to love themselves Ashley
Harrison good morning good to see you
good morning so this book is so
beautiful and I gotta tell you I read it
to my daughter last night Marion and I
my wife um and it made me cry because
the you describe a little girl who has a
big heart Big Dreams a big laugh but who
grows and grows and ultimately the words
that people use around her make her feel
small how did it come to you this story
well the story is inspired by a lot of
things particularly my own childhood my
own feelings around my body but really I
wanted to be able to express something
that's so internal and put it on the
page so people can maybe you know
connect with the character on this
really emotional level understand maybe
what she's going through how she feels
boxed in and how she feels trapped by
those labels no but by loving your
author's note you said my size indicated
to adults I was big enough to know
better even though I was still just a
kid that's what got me too man yeah yeah
you know part of this story is mine but
it's bigger than me I wanted to address
bigger things in our society like
adultification bias of black girls and
anti-fat bias as a metric for that and
it's you know it's an unfortunate thing
but I wanted to be able to express you
know we should care for these kids and
offer them the nurturing and innocence
that they deserve well because big is I
keep going back to two she has Big
Dreams big heart big laugh but then big
becomes a negative word right explain
that to me you know I can't explain it
it happens in our society in ways that
are so subtle and what I wanted to
express is how when we use words with
kids we don't really know what's going
to stick with them our society does have
this sort of understanding of bigness
but I wanted to reclaim that for the
character allow her to make more space
for herself and you know that happens
kind of physically on the page but you
know I hope that kids know that it's
okay to make space for their emotions
and for their feelings and expressing
themselves and you didn't give her a
name I kept thinking what's her name you
deliberately didn't name I did that on
purpose because you know she's not me
she's not one girl I wanted her to
represent black girls in black girlhood
but I also wanted any reader to maybe
see a reflection of themselves in her or
for you to see maybe a person you know
in their story and want to share it with
them and the pink matters here too pink
was a big deal for you pink was
important I wanted to stay fully within
that character's perspective throughout
the entire book but you know pink and
color psychology refers to things like
nurturing and care and those are all
things that this character deserves so I
feel like it's just a subtle way to
create this kind of empathy for her
you've read this book to Children what
was the response that you received it's
been really good kids have a very strong
sense of justice so often you know it's
kind of rough to read through some of
the bullying and this and the sadder
moments but they have very sense of
strong sense of justice and they want to
stand up for this girl and so I feel
very confident that they you know are
ready armed with the
um the knowledge and care that it takes
to to live in this world do this great
thing as a as an illustrator by making
the words physical almost like weapons
right like there's she's being battered
with them and then at a key Point she
says these are yours and she hands the
words back to people and they hurt me
yeah it's such a beautiful concept that
you draw but then the writing also
stands out you've been in illustrator
for a long time did you always also want
to be a writer no I was scared to be a
writer but I realized I was a
Storyteller and once I realized I had a
story to tell I kind of got over the
fear of writing
um but this book doesn't have that many
words I wanted to really do a lot of
Storytelling with the color and the
lighting and the composition yeah you
said even you're you're very deliberate
in your font choices I love how you
described vashti as a best-selling
Creator not author not illustrator but a
best-selling Creator I love that
description of you yeah I I hope that it
is an encompassing term because I want
to be able to create stories that reach
children especially to meet them where
they are if it's not in books maybe it's
through I don't know other stories
television animation anything wherever
kids are I want to meet them well we
were saying the illustrations are
beautiful you call them word there are
some spreads there are no words
whatsoever you call them wordless
spreads and what is your point there
just the pure emotion of it you know
when it's powerful exactly when we can
just kind of be a little bit more quiet
books are very intimate sometimes you
might be a kid reading it alone or
you're reading it at night time with a
young person I wanted those quiet
spreads to to give space to the story so
we can really sit in those emotions and
connect with the girl in the story we
appreciate you joining us the book is
incredible it is so I know it's well
done it's a children's book but adults
can take so much away from 100 thank you
so much big is on sale now wherever
you'd like to buy your books